مع ارتفاع عدد
النازحين وعدم توفر اماكن صالحه
لواء وندره وصول المواد الغذائيه الكافيه
وانعدامها بشكل كامل في كثير من المناطق
في شمال قطاع غزه يواجه اكثر من نصف مليون
من ابناء شعبنا في شمال قطاع غزه خطر
الموت جوعا نحن نتحدث عن قرابه 600000
فلسطيني من النساء والاطفال
والرجال
يتعرض هؤلاء لخطر الموت جوعا وهذه حقيقه
وليست مبالغه اذ يتضورون جوعا بشكل يومي
تمر عليهم ايام تلو ايام دون ان يدخل الى
جوف احدهم اي طعام لانعدام المواد
الغذائيه وكل انواع الطعام من الخضروات او
المعلبات او
غيرها من ادنى متطلبات الحياه للانسان ان
هذا الوض الضع الانسانيه الكارثيه الخطير
الذي لا يمكن توصيفه باي عبارات تقال في
تقارير اعلاميه او في اخبار ولا يمكن ان
توصف تداعياته على اكثر من مليوني فلسطيني
بسبب عدم وصول هذه المساعدات الاغاثه
والغذائيه لا سما الطحين اذ اضطر سكان
شمال قطاع غزه لطحن علف الحيوانات
لاستخدامه كغذاء يسد الام الجوع كي يظلوا
على قيد
الحياه ازاء هذا الوضع الانساني الكارثي
والمتفائل ينذر بارتفاع اعداد الشهداء
الذين ان لم يرتقوا بالقصف والحرق والموت
تحت الركام بسلاح امريكي صهيوني فانهم
يرتقون جوعا وعطشا ومرضا